which circles are divided into fourths
select all that apply well to be divided
into fourths that means we have to be
divided into four equal sections because
a fourth is going to be one of the four
equal sections so all of these are
divided into four sections but not all
of them are divided into four equal
sections for example this one it's
divided into four sections but this
section right over here is bigger than
this section right over here and it's
bigger than this section over here so
this isn't four equal sections
but these top three it looks like four
equal sections it looks like each of
these four sections are equal each of
these four sections are equal each of
these four sections are equal so all of
these all of these up here are divided
into fourths and this one isn't so I
won't click on that one let's keep going
this is fun which squares are divided
into fourths select all that apply well
same idea we have to be divided into
four equal sections so all of these are
divided into four sections one two three
four one two three four but not all of
them are divided into four equal
sections
for example this one right over here
this section is this little triangle is
much smaller than this section so these
aren't equal sections but for the other
three they are four equal sections this
is each of these triangles that this
square is divided into these are all
equal they all have the same area so
that's four equal sections each of these
smaller squares they all have the same
area so that's four equal sections and
then each of these four rectangles are
all the same size they all have the same
area so that's four equal sections let's
keep going I'm having a lot of fun all
right which circles are divided into
thirds well if you're to divide two
thirds you have to be divided into three
equal sections
so this one is divided into four equal
sections so this is divided into fourths
so it's not thirds this is divided into
three sections but they're not equal
this section right over here is smaller
than this section right over here this
one is divided into three sections and
they're all equal this section has the
same area as this section has the same
area as that section so I'll check that
one this one is three
but they're not equal just like this one
this one this section is much smaller
than this section so this is the only
one that is really divided into thirds
which circles are divided into thirds
same idea this is divided into fourths
these aren't equal sections not equal
sections
this one is divided into thirds let's do
one more
which rectangles are divided into
fourths remember for its it needs to be
four equal sections this looks like four
equal sections this is two equal
sections this is divided into halves not
fourths this is four equal sections this
is divided into six equal sections so
it's equal sections but not four it's
six equal sections so this right here is
divided into sixths so our two
rectangles that are divided into fourths
are this one and that one four equal
sections